Ein Amazon-Logistikcenter in Deutschland
– heimlich gefilmt.
Hier wird, so Greenpeace,
neue Ware vernichtet.
Amazon erntete einen Shitstorm.
Diese Vernichtung von Neuwaren,
die Vernichtung von Ressourcen ist einfach
nicht mehr tragbar in Zeiten der Klimakrise.
Die Kampagne stellt
den Online-Riesen an den Pranger
– und schärft das Bewusstsein
gegen Verschwendung.
Hinter jedem Textil
stecken ja wertvolle Ressourcen.
Ein Textil kommt mit bis zu 3000
verschiedenen Chemikalien in Berührung
während der Produktion,
verbraucht extrem viel Wasser.
Bei ’nem normalen weißen Baumwollshirt,
so das Einfachste, was man herstellen kann,
geht man schon so von
2.700 Liter[n] Wasser aus.
Das ist so viel, wie ein Mensch
in zweieinhalb Jahren trinkt.
Das Problem beim Online-Handel:
Es wird viel zurückgeschickt.
Nicht immer lohnt sich die Aufarbeitung.
20 Millionen Artikel werden
jedes Jahr entsorgt.
Er hat das ausgerechnet:
Logistiker Björn Asdecker.
Aber ist der Online-Handel überhaupt
das größte Problem?
Allein aufgrund der Handelsvolumina
ist der stationäre Handel noch deutlich größer
als der Online-Handel.
Es kommt zwar zu weniger Retouren,
also zu Rückgaben im Handel,
aber dafür haben wir diese Überbestände,
die enorm sind.
Die Branche wuchs rasant:
Wer in Deutschland lebt,
gab vor Corona im Schnitt mehr als
900 Euro im Jahr für Bekleidung aus
– ein Marktvolumen von 76 Milliarden Euro.
Der Hauptteil: preiswerte Fast Fashion.
Die größten Zuwächse waren die Ketten,
die preisgünstig Mode angeboten haben.
Sich modisch zu kleiden für kleines Geld,
ist natürlich schon für viele Leute,
auch für jüngere Menschen, die jetzt natürlich
noch nicht so viel verdienen,
’n hochattraktives Modell.
Corona traf den Handel als Schock.
Drei Lockdowns,
dazwischen Rabattschlachten.
Wohin mit der bereits bestellten Ware?
Der Handel blieb auf Bergen
von Kleidung sitzen,
Wintersachen zum Beispiel,
die sich im Sommer nicht verkaufen lassen.
Es geht um gewaltige Mengen.
Insgesamt 800 Millionen Textilien,
die neu produziert wurden,
die nicht verkauft wurden.
Und das ist die sogenannte
Corona-Kollektion;
das heißt, was mit denen jetzt passiert,
ist komplett unklar.
Viele Händler haben wirklich einfach
angegeben, dass sie [die] vernichten wollen.
Massenhaft Neuware zur Vernichtung?
In Deutschland wäre das gar nicht erlaubt.
Totaler Unsinn, das stimmt nicht.
Diese Furcht kann ich Greenpeace nehmen,
das ist nicht passiert.
Dass tatsächlich neue Ware,
die man verkaufen kann, vernichtet wird,
da kennen wir keinen Fall.
Gut, wir kennen natürlich nicht
alle 20.000 Unternehmen,
wir gucken ja nicht hinter jede Tür, ’ne?
Also, es kann … vielleicht in Extremfällen …
weiß ich’s nicht, aber wir kennen persönlich
keinen einzigen Fall.
Auch der Online-Riese Amazon sieht sich
zu Unrecht an den Pranger gestellt:
Tatsächlich liegt die Zahl der von Amazon
verkauften und versandten Produkte,
die entsorgt werden müssen,
im Promillebereich
– und wir arbeiten intensiv daran,
die Zahl immer weiter zu reduzieren.
Verramschen, spenden, einlagern, recyceln:
Für vieles beauftragen die Händler weitere
Firmen, Zwischenhändler und Entsorger.
So ist schwer nachvollziehbar,
was mit welchen Textilien geschieht.
Wenn sie jetzt ’ne Studie machen
über die Entsorgung im stationären Handel
oder die Entsorgung von den Überbeständen,
die sich jetzt in der Corona-Zeit
aufgetan haben
– dann werden Sie da
keine Teilnehmer bekommen.
Dann wird einfach keiner mitmachen,
weil darüber nicht gesprochen werden soll.
Im letzten Jahr hat Deutschland
seine Gesetze verschärft:
Die Vernichtung neuwertiger Ware
ist nun offiziell verboten.
Vor allem aber soll das Gesetz
für mehr Transparenz sorgen.
Frage an den Wissenschaftler:
Wird das klappen?
Man muss dazu sagen, dass dieses Gesetz
nur Hersteller und Händler erfasst.
Diese ganzen Mittelsmänner,
also Plattformen,
die Entsorgungsunternehmen,
da wurde so ’ne Flanke offen gelassen,
die in der Praxis dazu führen wird,
dass dieses Gesetz an vielen Stellen
’n zahnloser Tiger bleiben wird.
Was also hilft?
Brauchen wir wirklich immer mehr Klamotten?
In Deutschland hat jede Person
im Schnitt 95 Kleidungsstücke
– jedes fünfte davon wird nie getragen.
Der beste Klimaschutz ist Alltagsaktivismus,
weg vom Neukaufen.
Egal ob sich’s um Elektronikgeräte handelt
oder um Bücher
oder eben auch um Kleidungsstücke:
Leihen, mieten, teilen, tauschen
– die Modelle gibt es, und die müssen jetzt
halt auch staatlich unterstützt werden.
Das Problem allerdings:
Noch immer ist „shoppen gehen“
in Deutschland
eines der beliebtesten Hobbys.